>>Lealea Jones responds to the Davos Question
Hi, I'm Lealea Jones and I'm with everyone
on this table but particularly Jan. Coming
from Hackney, I think that it would be an
amazing thing for the world leaders to go,
not only to Hackney, but somewhere that is
less fortunate and really see the lives of
people and what they're going through, you
know. I've been brought up in a place, like,
well in Hackney, where a lot of youths right
now are dying, babies, children are killing
children. It's ridiculous and I think they
need to see that. They need to be there and
be able to see and see what they're going
through and the reasons why they're doing
it and put that support into it. They need
to know and to understand why, why are they
doing this and I think that's the only way
they'll really be able to gain that knowledge
is to go and experience it for themselves.
>>Jan
Stop the violence.
>>Lealea Jones
Stop the violence. Exactly, but not just in
Hackney, but everywhere in the world that
is affected by that sort of problem.